[موسيقى]
مساؤكم نحييكم هذه التاسعه هذا المساء
وهذه عناوينها
على وقع يا عزيزي الرصاص حرب اعلاميه
بينكيف وموسكو حول السيطره على ضخمه
وفي السودان امل بالتزام اطراف القتال
باتفاق جده وصولا الى سلام دائما وعوده
نازحين
ناطحات السحاب روائع نيويورك العمرانيه
تهدد باغراقها ومنها قد تكون ضحيه الاولى
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء نبدا من
تطورات المهمه السعوديه للفضاء حيث وصل
رائده الفضاء السعودييان علي القرني وريان
برناوي الى مركز كندي للفضاء بولايه
فلوريدا حيث ستنطلق المركبه التي ستقل علي
وريان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه بعد ثلاث
ساعات وودع كل من علي القرني وريان برناوي
اهاليهما قبل الانتقال الى منطقه تجهيز
الصعود على مركبه الاطلاق طبعا سنتابع
معكم مسار هذه الرحله اولا باول وسنستعرض
خلال التاسعه هذا المساء ابرز مراحلها
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله تكمل يمكن
صعوبه
على كيفيه التعايش داخل المحطه الفضاء
الدوليه من اهداف الباحثين هو العلماء
والمطورين اللي على الارض يجربوا تجاربهم
هذه في الفضاء دوري الان هو اني امثل
المملكه في هذه المهمه العلميه بشكل عام
تثبت او او تمكننا من القدره على النجاح
في هذه المهمه وتعد هذه البعثات الفضائيه
هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه ويوصل طموحنا
لعنان السماء
الى اوكرانيا وتحديدا مدينه بخمت سقطت بيد
الروس او لم تسقط اعلانات نصر ورفع اعلام
ووعود بمكافات وجوائز يتناوب عليها الرئيس
الروسي وقائد فاجنر بعد اعلان احكام
السيطرهم على بخمه اعلان عززه قول الرئيس
الاوكراني بان بخمد قابعه في قلوب
الاوكرانيين فقط واعتبر اقرارا منه
بسقوطها ليعود بتصريحات اخرى ليؤكد ان
قوته لا تزال متواجده في ضخمه
بعد ان اثارت تصريحاته جدلا كبيرا حيال
سقوط ضخمه بايدي القوات الروسيه اكد
الرئيس الاوكراني
ان قوته لا تزال متواجده في بخمت
اليوم يقومون بمهمه بالغه الاهميه وهم في
باخموت حتى اليوم ولكن لن اخبرك في اي
موقع بالضبط لكن هذا يعني ان بخموت لم يتم
احتلالها من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
الاقرار الضمني بالخساره لم ياتي اقل الى
من صور الدمار التي تشحت بها ضخمه بعد
اكثر من 200 يوم من هذا القتال الشرس رئيس
الاوكراني
حاصر وجود المدينه التي تبلغ مساحتها 41
كيلومترا بقلوب اوكرانيين بقوله بخنط هي
اليوم في قلوبنا فقط وضفنا ضخمه اصبحت
مدمره بالكامل لا مباني مشيده صامده في
المدينه الا القليل وفق تعبيره
اعتقد اننا فقدنا السيطره على مدينه باغ
لكن عليكم ان تفهموا انها تحولت الى لا
شيء الروس دمروها بالكامل لا يوجد فيها
بناء الامر ماساوي اليوم بامكاننا القول
ان باخم فقط في قلوبنا لا يوجد شيء هناك
الا الدمار والكثير من القتل الروس الذين
اتوا الينا
الامال الاوكرانيه الضيقه التي تمللت
بينما تبقى في بخمت من جدران سقطت هي
الاخرى فالمدينه انتقلت من اي دي اوكرانيا
الى روسيا وفقنا اعلنه على الاقل رئيس
روسيا هل قواته بالسيطره على مدينه بخموت
باستخدام اسمها الذي يعود الى الحقبه
السوفيتيه ارتيوموفيسك حيث قائد فاجنر
وبخلفيه لا تتعدى تسعه جنود حاملين على مي
روسيا وفاجنر اعلن الانتصار في المعركه
التي استمرت 224 يوما اكد بريغوجين ان
قوته ستبدا الانسحاب من المدينه المدمره
اعتبارا من يوم الخميس مسلما بذلك اول
انتصار بارز لبوتين في اوكرانيا كما وعد
اذا اشهر من المعارك الداميه جاءت بتكلفه
كبيره على الطرفين من حيث العديد والعتاد
فيما المدينه اطحت حطاما في معركه بخمض
خسرت فيها فاجنر الاف المقاتلين معظمهم من
المدنيين الذين جندوا من السجون الروسيه
هذه الخساره وان صحت ستمثل جائزه نيوتن
رغم عدم اهميه المدينه استراتيجيا فجائزه
سيكافئ فيها فعليا كل جندي تميز في هذه
المعركه وسيقلده وسامه شرف استحقه وفق
قوله
[موسيقى]
الفك الروسي اطبق على مدينه بخمت الواقعه
الشرقي اوكرانيا واستمات في الحصول عليها
رغم اهميتها الاستراتيجيه القليله مفرمه
اللحم وصف لم ياتي من عدم فخسائر باهظه
ومؤلمه المت بالطرفين لاسيما روسيا وفاجنر
لتطرح تساؤلات كثيره عن استحقاق هذه
المدينه للثمن المدفوع اهميه ضخمه
الاستراتيجيه ضئيله ومتواضعه لكنها اطحت
رمزا معنويا للطرفين فبالنسبه لموسكو
وتحقيق تقدم او نص وان كان متواضعا هو
بالغ الاهميه في هذه المرحله بعد ان امضت
قوتها اشهرا بمحاولات اسقاط المدينه دون
جدوى قبل تدخل فاجنر وتحولها لراس حرب
هناك كما نسيطر على بخمه وفق اعتقاد الروس
قد تخولهم تقدم اكثر في دنيتك وسيطر على
هذه المنطقه الاوكرانيه الشرقيه لكن
الاهميه الكبرى للقبض على ضخمه تتمثل في
ضرب معنويات الق الاوكرانيه وحتى توجيه
رساله للغرب باستمرار المكاسب رغم الدعم
العسكري الجبار الكيف وفق ما تقوله
ديليجراف غير ان رسائل روسيا كلفتها باهضه
في بخمه وفي محيطها
بمقتل ما بين 20 الى 30 الف روسي وفق
تقديرات غربيه واستخباراتيه رغم تفادي
الدفاع الروسيه الاعلان عن خسائرها
البشريه الكلفه العسكريه لم تكن اقل ثمنا
من حيث العتاد والاسلحه المدمره اما
المدينه الخاليه من سكانها البالغ عددهم
73 الفا فهي مدمره بالكامل
[موسيقى]
وايضا من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
رشد اهلا بكم معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
محمد ابدا معك لماذا تاتي التصريحات من
الجانب الاوكراني لا نريد ان نقول متضاربه
ولكن غير متصقه فيما يتعلق بمصير بخمت ومن
يسيطر عليها الان
يعني يمكن القول ان هذه التصريحات وتضارب
المعلومات التي تخرج من القياده السياسيه
والقياده العسكريه في الجيش الاوكراني هي
ترسم واقع الحال في مدينه بخمس الان يمكن
القول يعني قبل حوالي ساعه من الان كان
هناك احد ضباط الجيش الاوكراني من الحرس
القومي الاوكراني خرج بتسجيل فيديو ومباشر
عبر التواصل الاجتماعي من احد المباني
السكانيه داخل مدينه بخموت هناك بعض جيوب
الجيش الاوكراني تسيطر على منطقه وتعتبر
حي صغير جدا في مدينه باخمت ولكن مدينه
باخمت فعليا هي ساقطه عسكريا بيد القوات
الروسيه اكثر من ثمانيه وتسعين بالمائه من
مساحه هذه المدينه تحت سيطره الملك يعني
تحت مرمى نيران الجيش الروسي والسيطره
لذلك لا يمكن الحديث ان اوكرانيا يعني
تسيطر على مدينه او فقدت السيطره بشكل
كامل على مدينه لان يعني الحجم الكبير
والمساحه الجغرافيه الكامله لمدينه
القوات الروسيه الان العمليه والجيش
الاوكراني لا يركز عملياته داخل مدينه
داخل يعني يقوم بعمليات في محيط مدينه من
الجهه الشماليه والجنوبيه وان كانت بعد
التصريحات التي تاتي من الجانب الاوكراني
تنفي ذلك نذهب الى عبد الجواد عبد الجواد
هل من رد فعل روسي على بعض التصريحات
الاوكرانيه التي تنفي السيطره الروسيه على
ضخمه
مساء الخير نادين لك ولي محمد في الحقيقه
خرج اليوم وتحدث بشكل واضح عبر مقطع فيديو
تم نشره على العديد من مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ومنها صفحته الرسميه في
تيليجرام يتحدث فيه عن عدم وجود اي جندي
اوكراني داخل مدينه باخموت معللا هذا لسبب
بان قوات فاجنر اليوم لا يمكنها القبض او
الحصول على ايه اسرى من قوات الجيش
الاوكراني هو تحدث بان الرئيس هولندي
مرزيلينسكي لا يعرف جيدا ما يحدث الان في
بخموت لذلك طبعا عندما نرى وزاره دفاع
موسكو نادين تتحدث عن اعلان السيطره بشكل
كامل على مدينه باخمط رغم التزامها الصمت
خلال الفتره الاخيره حيال تصريحات هذا كما
ترى الدائره السياسيه والتحليل العسكري في
البلاد في روسيا هو حقيقه نوعا ما كما هذا
الوضع الكرملين وصف هذا الشيء بالحقيقه
وتحدث عن السيطره مجلس الامن الروسي وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ومقاطع
الفيديو تنتشر من هناك نادين يعني ليس هو
مقطع فيديو واحد كما يدور الحديث وانما هي
عده مقاطع فيديو حتى انه تم رفع علم
مجموعه فاجنر فوق اعلى نقطه في مدينه
بختموت وكان هناك محاولات
بقذائف هاون من خارج المدينه لاصطياد تلك
الموضع هذه هي الاخبار طبعا تنتشر كالنار
في الهشيم على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
كما ذكرت وفي تيليجرام باكبر نسبه لذلك
الوضع هو ماساوي كما يتحدث البعض في باك
موت هناك سيطره لقوات فاجنر هي ايام
معدوده اربع ايام متبقيه لتسليم هذه
المدينه للجيش الروسي حسب روايه
اذا هذا هو الموقف والتاكيد الروسي اعود
مره اخرى الى كيف محمد عندما يقول
زيلينسكي انا بخمت لم يتبقى منها شيء ماذا
يدور وفق مراقبين هل يعني بان السيطره
الروس لها رمزيه معنويه وليست استراتيجيه
فيما يتعلق بتطور المعارك
نعم بالفعل يعني ما حصل في ضخمه ودمار
كبير وشامل لتلك المدينه ويعني قائد
القوات المسلحه البريه الاوكرانيه قال ان
معظم الابنيه او جميع الابنيه السكنيه قد
تضررت بفعل العمليات العسكريه على مدى
يعني اكثر من 200 واربعين يوما الجيش
الروسي استخدم يعني سياسه الارض او
استراتيجيه الارض المحروقه بتدمير لجميع
المباني السكنيه لجميع مراكز القوات
الاوكرانيه خاصه بعد اجراء جميع المدنيين
خلال الفتره الماضيه ولكن ما يعني ما الذي
سيحدث خلال الايام القليله المقبله خاصه
بعد اعلان يعني سحب مجموعات يوم الخميس في
الخامس والعشرين هل ستستطيع القوات
الروسيه البقاء والحفاظ على تلك المدينه
خاصه مع الانباء ان يعني الهجوم المضاده
التي تعد له اوكرانيا وربما ستبدا بهجوم
في مدينه او في محور يعني محور ماريانكا
يعني ننتظر الايام القليله المقبله ولكن
الجيش الاوكراني يقول انه الان يقوم
بسياسه قد تبعتها القوات الروسيه في
السابق وهي حصار واطباق الحصار على مدينه
باخمت وتتمدد القوات الاوكرانيه من الجهه
الجنوبيه للحصار وقطع خطوط الامداد من
الجهه الجنوبيه وايضا من الجهه الشماليه
ايضا تتمدد القوات الاوكرانيه ربما هذا
سيكون استعدادا لاقتحام القوات الاوكرانيه
لتلك المنطقه هذه النقاط التي تتحدث عنها
محمد سنقلها الى عبد الجواد عبد الجواد
اليوم امام هذه التصريحات المتضاربه هناك
من يقول انه لكي نفهم هذا التبرير لهذا
التضارب في التصريحات عندما تقول روسيا
بان السعاده السيطره على بخمه اي المناطق
جغرافيا بالتحديد لكي نفهم
يعني عندما يدور الحديث بالسيطره على باف
موت يدور الحديث عن الحدود الرسميه
للمدينه قد تكون جيوب موجوده تحدثت عنها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه يوم امس يتواجد فيها
بعض مقاتلي او جنود الجيش الاوكراني قد
تكون هذه الجيوب خارج الحدود المدنيه
المرسومه اصلا لهذه المدينه لكن يعني حتى
هذه اللحظه لا يمكن الارتكاز الا عن
الاعلان الرسمي بما يخص قضيه السيطره على
تخرج الرئيس فواديمير بوتينيومس وتم اصدار
بيان رسمي كما نشره على موقع بان كافه
ارجاء المدينه اليوم هي تحت سيطره قوات
فاجنر اما هذه الجيوب حسب روايه مجموعه
فاكنار فهي تقع خارج المدينه ومنها طبعا
يتم استهداف داخل المدينه عبر قذائف
للهاوين وغير هذا من هذا الشيء لذلك نادين
طبعا ارض ضخمه يعني المحدده على الخريطه
هي تحت سيطره مجموعه حسب روايه
ولم يتم التاكيد من موسكو على هذه الحدود
سوى السيطره على هذه المدينه
شكرا جزيلا لك ونشكر ايضا محمد بابا من
شكرا لكم
ومستمرون معكم اذا في التاسعه هذا المساء
وفي جديد اخبار الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
التغذيه العسكريه لاوكرانيا والتي تمت
بالتنقيط قد تكون ساهمت بالتقليل من
مكاسبها السريعه او المحافظه عليها
فالاتحاد الاوروبي يدين باعتذار لاوكرانيا
ورئيسها لبطئه بشكل صادم في تعبئه مواردها
وفق صحيفه ديل التليجراف البريطانيه ففي
وقت سارع الدول عده لتقديم المساعده
كابولندا وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده
تلكات دول اخرى وكان ردها بطيء للغايه على
طلبات زيلينسكي اليائسه والمتكرره الدعم
العسكري الغربي لاوكرانيا تمثل بالقذائف
والصواريخ اولا ثم مركبات م درعه ومجموعه
من الدبابات وصولا الان ربما للمقاتلات
تيليجراف اكدت امتلاك تحالف النيتو لاليات
مشتركه ولكنه ببساطه لا يستخدمها مبديه
ضروره مراجعه هذه الدول لمعدل انفاقها على
الحرب وطالما ان الحرب لن تبقى في
اوكرانيا ان فاز بوتين وفق هذه الصحيفه
الانظمه المصممه لحمايه العاصمه الروسيه
من هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار تحبط الانشطه
اليوميه للسكان وباتت محور الشكاوى
الرياضيين وحتى سائقي سيارات الاجره حيث
عطلت معدات التشويش نظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي gps وسط موسكو وكذلك الساعات
الذكيه وبالتالي عرقل التطلعات اكثر من 20
الف عداء في نصف مره موسكو الاسبوع الماضي
للتغلب على افضل الاوقات الشخصيه فمتتبع
السرعه والمسافه فشلوا بمتابعه الرياضيين
بعد تجاوز اثر كذلك على تطبيق استدعاء
سيارات الاجره وتنظيم عمليات النقل بين
السائقين والركب
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو اسبوعين على انطلاق المحادثات
السودانيه في جده بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وافقت طرفان على وقف اطلاق النار
مدته اسبوع يبدا غدا مع احتمال تمديده
لاحقا وبانتظار دخول الهدنه حيزه تنفيذ
يفترض على كلا الطرفين منذ لحظه توقيع
الاتفاق ولمده 48 ساعه عدم السعي وراء
تحقيق اي مكاسب عسكريه على الارض بمعنى
اخر وقف للشبكات تماما يفترض خلال تلك
الفتره اي 48 ساعه ان يبلغ الجيش والدعم
السريع قوتهما بشروط هذا الاتفاق وتوجيهما
الامتثال بوقف النار في جميع انحاء البلاد
على الجانبين اذا وقف كافه الهجمات
والاعمال العدائيه بما في ذلك هجمات
القناصه واستهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
او حتى المراكز السكانيه كذلك تلتزم
القوتان العسكريتان بعدم تقويه الدفاعات
او اعاده الامداد او توزيع الاسلحه او
الامدادات العسكريه بما في ذلك من مصادر
اجنبيه
تمتنعان عن احتلال المستشفيات ومرافق
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه بما في ذلك منشات
المياه والكهرباء والوقود يتعهد الطرفان
بوقف اي اعمال تتعلق بالاخفاء القصري او
الاحتجاز التعسفي والتعذيب للاشخاص اي
التزام بالقوانين الدوليه المتعلقه بحقوق
الانسان
احنا كشعب سوداني بنعول عليه كثير جدا جدا
اول حاجه ايقاف ايقاف الحرب بين الطرفين
في غاز اطلاق النار بين الطرفين ويكون
ايقاف لانه عندنا تجارب سابقه
ايقاف النار للاسف اتهزمت قالوا اي قوه
تكون قاعده فيه في مناطق يعني
محتل بيوت ناس فقعد في مناطق فيها يعني
كميه مهوله من المواطنين ومن السكان
فمفروض يتراجع الكلام ده تطبق للحاجات
الانسانيه
للمستشفيات دفن الجثث وكده لازم يتطبق
الناس تقعد في حته واحده وتتفاوض ويوقفوا
الضرب حاجه يسمع الحارب دي يوقفوها لانه
بعد شويه
الاتفاق اللي حصل في جده
اطلاق النار نتمنى الاتفاق ده يطبق
النار وقتلا المدنيين والخراب اللي حصل ان
هذه الحرب قادر على اليابسه الاخضر هو
اصلا ما كان الاخضر كان بقى قليل لكن الان
هذه الحرب عليهم محتاجين يعني محتاجين
لانه
المعونات تصل كما هي للمواطنين الحياه
تسير المواطن يكون في اطمئنان يكون في
حياه طيبه يعني يعيش الانسان في هذا البلد
يعني وهذا الوطن الوطني كبير وطن عريض
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك الصحه في
عمار ابو شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء بانتظار دخول الهدنه
حيز التنفيذ يوم غد هل من مناطق ما زالت
مشتعله حتى الان في الساعه الاخيره
اهلا بك
نعم في هذه الساعات ليس هنالك اشتعالا
لعدد من المناطق باستثناء منطقه سلاح
المهندسين في مدينه ام درمان التي تدور
فيها اشتباكات منذ اكثر من ساعه ونصف
باعتبارها منطقه استراتيجيه لعدد من
القوات العسكريه التي تتمركز فيها قوات
الجيش السوداني وترد على عدد من الهجمات
من قوات الدعم السريع في الجانب الاخر هذه
المنطقه تشتعل منذ عده ايام وكان الجيش قد
بسط فيها السيطره وما زال بشكل واضح وكبير
قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث من مصادر مقربه
لها بانها في محاوله الدخول لهذه المنطقه
باعتبارها ايضا منطقه تؤمن من خلالها عدد
من المواقع المهمه جدا في منطقه غربيه ومن
درمان هنا في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وشرق
العاصمه الخرطوم هدات الاحوال بشكل كبير
ليس هنالك ذوي
للمدافع وليس هنالك ايضا تحليق للطيران
الحربي التابع للجيش السوداني ليس هنالك
ايضا رد من المضادات الارضيه هدات الاحوال
بشكل واضح وكبير في مدينه بحري ربما هي
الاقل حده من مدينه ام دروان ووسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وشرق العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا في هذه اللحظات ومع
الترتيب لهذا المباشر بث الجيش فيديو عبر
موقع او صفحتها على الفيسبوك صفحات القوات
المسلحه لقوات الجيش وهي تمشط وتعلن بشكل
واضح تمشيط منطقه السوق العربي بشكل كامل
وكبير اما يعني انها استطاعت ان تبسط
السيطره على هذه المنطقه بحسب هذا الفيديو
المنشور واعلنت من خلالها انها استطاعت ان
تتقدم خطوات متقدمه
التي تمثل ايضا بعدا
منطقه السوق العربي هي منطقه السوق العربي
في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم التي كانت تدور
فيها اشتباكات ومناوشات ما بين قوات الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش الفيديو الذي بثه
الجيش قبل قليل يؤكد بانه استطاع السيطره
على هذه المنطقه بشكل واضح وكبير ننتظر في
الساعات القادمه وربما بيان الجيش ليؤكد
ذلك اكثر ويوضح موقف العمليات في هذه
المنطقه بعد ان بث هذا الفيديو والذي وضح
من خلالها انه وقت النهار صور وقت النهار
الان الاحوال تبدو هادئه وبالنسبه كبيره
باستثناء منطقه
المهندسين سلاح المهندسين في مدينه ام
درمان طيب
وضع المنشات المرافق التي تحول بعضها
لسكنات هل يتم اخلائها تدريجيا هل رشحت اي
معلومات وصلتكم
ليس هنالك اخلاء بشكل واضح وفوري ومنفذ
على ارض الواقع هنالك مصادر ميدانيه وشود
عيان تحدثوا ان هنالك تحرك لعدد من القوات
خاصه قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه العرضه
ومناطق شارع الاربعين بمدينه ام درمان
ولكن ليس هنالك اخلاء يبدو واضح لهذه
المناطق خاصه وان عدد من المستشفيات ما
زالت تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريع ربما
يتم ذلك من خلال التنفيذ الفوري والفعلي
لتطبيق الهدنه باعلان القوات الدعم السريع
خروجها وانسحابها من هذه المؤسسات الطبيه
وحتى عدد كبير من المساكن المتواجده في
العاصمه الخرطوم سواء على مستوى مدينه
بحري او مدينه ام درمان او على مستوى هنا
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ولكن ليس هنالك
معلومه مؤكده من قوات الدعم السريع او حتى
من الجيش بان هنالك اخلاق تم بالفعل لعدد
من المواقع التي تم تضمينها ضمن البنود
المهمه في اعلان الجد الاخير والموقع على
اتفاقيه هدنه قصيره الامد شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات وهذه الاحاطه من
الخرطومه الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
هذا وتستقبل ولايه الجزيره اعدادا كبيره
من الفارين من الحرب التي بدات في منتصف
الشهر الماضي بين الجيش ودعم السريع مفاوض
العون الانساني بالسودان قال ان هناك
حوالي 170 الف اسره تحتاج لمساعدات عاجله
لسان حالي اهل هذه المدينه ان بها من
الامان ما يجعلها قبله للناجين من رصاص
الحرب والباحثين عن الحياه
ودمدني التي تبعد حوالي 180 كيلومترا
جنوبي الخرطوم فتحت البيوت فيها وكذلك
المدارس والمراكز لاستقبال كل من اتخذها
مقصدا للنجاه من هذه الاسر
والفري من الاحداث الخرطوم
قصدوا ولايه الجزيره بشكل اساسي والان
الولايات الجزيره
بتستضيف اعداد كبيره جدا
في مراكز ايواء هناك حوالي 23 الى 24 مركز
تتوزع هذه المراكز بمدينه المدني محلات
المدني الكبرى وكذلك محليه شرق الجزيره في
مدينه رفاعه وكذلك في محلات الحصاحيصه
وكذلك محلات الكاملين
هنا في مدرسه المكنمر بمدينه ودمدني التي
تحولت الى مركز لاواء الناجين من رصاص
الحرب اجتهد الشابان مجتبى عبد الواحد
ومحمد عوض وتفرغ لتيسير مستلزمات الايواء
من ماكل ومشرب وتسكين لاكثر من
139 شخصا اغلبهم من الاطفال والنساء
فوفرنا دور بتاعه ايوى في البدايه كان
عددها ثلاثه مراكز يستضفنا العدد وصل لحد
312 فرد في البدايه
والحمد لله قدرنا نوفر لهم الاعاشه والسكن
والرعايه الطبيه حتى الرعايه النفسيه
نفسها
ثم ان القصص التي استمعنا اليها هنا جراء
الحرب والمشاهدات التي وقفنا عليها كثيره
بان تؤسس لمعنى ان اليقين من اوجب متطلبات
الحياه عند الازمات والملمات والله اعزي
علينا مبسوطين الحمد لله والشكر يا رب
العالمين
استقبلونا وفرهونا فرهوا ايالنا
الحمد لله يعني ما مخلي لنا شيء والله
يعني هم بيجوا زي اهلنا وقفوا معانا والله
بجد ما خلونا والله المركز واحد من حوالي
23 مركزا بالولايه تعمل في اتساق تام
للوقوف مع القادمين الى الولايه
والباحثين عن معادله الامن في زمن الحرب
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب استقبلت هذه الولايه
اعدادا كبيره من الفارينه من الحرب
واستطاعت المجهودات الشعبيه من استيعاب
هذه التدفقات البشريه الكبيره اما المكان
هنا فرحابه الناس تنسيهم الام المصائب
محمد عثمان العربيه من ولايه الجزيره
مدينه ود مدني
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
قبيله انطلاق مهمه السعوديه نحو الفضاء
العربيه تصحبكم بعرض افتراضيا للرحله
[موسيقى]
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله
التدريب نفسها فانه جدا مكثف تدريبات يوم
جملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل المحطه
الفضاء الدوليه ممن اهداف الباحثين او
العلماء والمطورين اللي على الارض يجلبوا
تجاربهم هادي في الفضاء دوري الان هو اني
امثل المملكه في هذه المهمه العلميه هذه
التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا من
القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وتعد هذه
البعثات الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه
ويوصل طموحنا لعنان السماء
السعوديه تدشن اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء
ضمن برنامج المملكه الذي يحدث لتاهيل
كوادر السعوديه متمرسه لخوض رحلات فضائيه
طويله وقصيره المدى والمشاركه في التجارب
العلميه والابحاب الدوليه المتعلقه
بالفضاء راى فضاء سعوديه في مهمه اي اكس 2
ريان وبرناوي وعلي القرني وبرفقه اخرين
امريكيين هما جون شفر وتجيني اختياره
برناوي والقرني اتى بعد خضوعهما لتدريبات
مكثفه واختبارات حاسمه كانت كفيله
بترشيحهما لهذه الرحله التي ستنطلق من
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
اكيد استاذ اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه
علميه فباذن الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه
علميه بحثيه رائده يعني لاول مره في
التاريخ باذن الله هذه التجارب تعنى
بمجالات متعدده اولها هي ثلاث تجارب
توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذه البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله
اذا مده المهمه 12 يوما سيقوم رواد الفضاء
فيها باجراء اربع عشره تجربه علميه تتعلق
بالدماغ والدم وعلوم الخلايا اضافه لتجارب
الاستمطار في الجاذبيه الصغرى علي القرني
شرح في لقاء مع العربيه طبيعه التجارب
الطبيه المنشوده والمعنيه بتغيرات الدماغ
والجهاز العصبي واكيدان انها ستتم بادوات
جديده تستخدم لاول مره نتابع
سوف نقوم باجراء سته تجارب في الطب البشري
وهذا التجارب تعنى بدراسه التغيرات على
التي قد تصيب الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام
وكذلك النظر هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها
في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انها
سوف يتم استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في
الفضاء بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه تجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 20 30 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
هذه المهمه تاتي ضمن احدى مبادرات الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء ولكن
انطلق مكانه المملكه في مجال الفضاء
وتطوير قدراتها البشريه والصناعيه وستساعد
هذه المهمه في تاهيل كوادر السعوديه لخوض
رحلات فضائيه طويله وقصيره المدى بجانب
المشاركه في تجارب العلميه الابحاث
الدوليه والمهام المستقبليه المتعلقه
بالفضاء خاصه متى يعرف بطب الفضاء وهو
تخصص حديث يعنى بشكل اساسي بصحه رواد
الفضاء قبل السفر وتاكد من قدرتهم على
التكيف في الفضاء
طبعا طب الفضاء هو تخصص حديث يعنى بصحه
رواد الفضاء هو يهدف للتاكد من صحه رواد
الفضاء قبل السفر للفضاء والتاكد من
سلامتهم خلال تواجدهم في بيئه الفضاء
الشديده والتاكد من صحتهم وقدرتهم على
التكيف بعد العوده للارض طبعا الاثر الاول
لهذه التجربه انها من اوائل التجارب
الطبيه في الفضاء بدعم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهذا يؤكد دعم المملكه للابحاث
الطبيه في مجالي الطب والفضاء
وهو تماشي مع رؤيه 2030 وايضا الاثر
الثاني هو التاكد من سلامه رواد الفضاء
ومساهمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه في تقدم
هذا المجال
وبناء التدابير المضاده لحمايه رواد
الفضاء في المستقبل
بتابع معكم اذا هذه صور المباشره حيث ان
العربيه تغطي اول باول جديد التحركات
والتحضيرات لهذه المهمه السعوديه حيث
ساعات قليله جدا تفصلنا عن طلاق الرحله
السعوديه التاريخيه نحو الفضاء وعلامتها
اول رائده فضاء سعوديه عربيه ومسلمه وهي
ريانه برناوي وايضا علي القرني الذي يعد
اول رائد فضاء سعودي يصل الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه طبعا كانت نشرت الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء على تويتر كل الصور المتعلقه
باكتمال الاستعدادات النهائيه لرايدي
الفضاء السعوديين قبيل انطلاق مهمتنا
مهمتهما العلميه التاريخيه هذه وطبعا ننقل
لكم صور التحضيرات وتجهيزات لمراحل
الانتقال يعني كنا شاهدنا مراحل صور
للتوديع من قبل الرائدين للاهالي وايضا
للناس المتحمسين لهم
اذا طريق صعب وشاق ينتظر رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين علي وريانا بعد ساعات من الان
زميل نايف الاحمر يعطينا عرضا افتراضيا عن
الرحله كيف ستبدا ومتى ستنتهي كل ذلك
بتقنيه الواقع المعزز
هذا ليس صاروخا يستخدم في حروب العصر
الحديث انه تالكون تسعه ذلك الصاروخ الذي
ينقلنا الى ابعد رحلات استكشافيه في الكون
وربما في اهم رحلات التنقيب عن اسرار
الفضاء وحل الغاز هذا الصاروخ مشاهدينا
تلتصق فيه مركبه دراغون التي نراها هنا
سيكون على متن دراغون اول امراه سعوديه
تحلق نحو الفضاء ريان برناوي وعلي القرني
رائد الفضاء السعودي يقومان برحله الى
فضاء الخارجي لزياره محطه الفضاء الدوليه
رفقه اثنين اخرين ضمن مهمتي
وهذه اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء لفريق رواد
سعوديين لتدشن المملكه عصرا جديدا في
استكشاف الفضاء وعلامه فارقه للحدث
التاريخي تعالوا معنا مشاهدينا لنص عذاب
الى الفضاء افتراضيا طبعا لكن حذاري انها
ليست كاي رحله الوصول الى الفضاء وحده
يستغرق نحو 24 ساعه قبل التحليق لابد
لرواد الفضاء من المرور بمراحل عده
وتدريبات مكثفه واختبارات حاسمه وهذا ما
مر به علي وريان بالطبع حيث خضع لكافه
البرامج التدريبيه التي تساعدهما على
اتمام هذه المهمه بنجاح واجراء التجارب
العلميه المتعلقه برحلتهما الى الفضاء
تبدا الرحله فعليا مشاهدينا بالصعود على
متن مركبه دراغون اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه
تنقل البشره الى المحطه الفضائيه تصل
حموله المركبه الى اربعه ركاب من والى
المدار نشاهد الركاب هنا في استديو
العربيه لكنها قادره مشاهدينا ايضا على
اعاده كميات كبيره من الحمولات الى الارض
لنستعد اذا لمرحله
الاطلاق
بعد انطلاقه من المنصه يصل الصاروخ لسرعه
الصوت ولا ننسى مشاهدينا ان الصاروخ يمر
باعلى منطقه ضغط هوائي ديناميكي
وبالارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا تتم عمليه
الانفصال الاول بعد سبع دقائق وحين يصل
لمدار الارض المنخفض يتم الانفصال الثاني
بعد ذلك ترتبط مركبه دراغون بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه هذه هي محطه الفضاء الدوليه في
هذه المرحله مشاهدينا يقوم الطاقه بمركبه
دراغون بعمل مناوره باستخدام الدافعات حتى
يتم الاقتراب والالتحام بالمحطه
ها قد وصلنا مشاهدينا اذا الى المحطه في
هذه الرحله سيجري رواد الفضاء السعوديون
14 تجربه رائده في الجاذبيه الصغرى بما
فيها تجارب توعويه تعليميه يشارك فيها 12
الف طالب وطالبه واثنان واربعون موقعا في
السعوديه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مهمات
كثيره ولافته بانتظار علي وريان في الفضاء
ونحن هنا على الارض ننتظر عودتهما من
الفضاء السالمين
اذا نتابع معكم الان هذه الصور المباشره
لرايدي الفضاء السعوديين الان نرى علي
وريانا بانتظار الذهاب الى المصعد لكي
يذهب الى هذه المركبه المركبه دراغون لكي
تحمل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين ضمن طاقم
مهمه اي اكس 2 الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره طبعا هذا
الصاروخ الذي ستذهب وتلتحم المركبه به
صاروخ فالكناين وايضا مركبه دراغون لحمل
رائدي الفضاء كما نتابع الان هم ذهب الى
المصعد على كل حال لنعرف المزيد من
التفاصيل نذهب الى مراسلي العربيه معنا من
فلوريدا حسين توضوا من الرياض هاني نصفيان
مرحبا بكما معنا في التاسع هذا المساء
حسين الكلمه لكي تعطينا جديد التفاصيل
والمعلومات حتى الساعه لهذه الرحله
اخر المعلومات نادين ما تفضلت به قبل
ثواني وهي ان علي وريان الان يتجهان نحو
المركبه دراغون هم قرب المصعد ودخل المصعد
ليسعدا الى قمه هذا الصاروخ والدخول الى
المركبه الفضائيه وهنا تجد الاشاره انها
اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه لنقل البشر الى
المحطه الفضائيه قبل ساعه تقريبا وصل علي
وريان الى مركز كندي للفضاء عبر مروحيه مع
رائدى الى الفضاء الامريكيين حيث لو حال
لاهاليهم واصدقائهم الذين اتوا الى هنا
كما تشاهدين الان يصعدان السلم هما يتجهان
الان نحو هذه
المركبه هذه البلدات التي تشاهدينها على
الشاشه هي بالذات خاصه لكل رائد فضاء صممت
لتناسب جسده طبعا كان هناك
ترتيبات اخيره اللمسات الاخيره لصحه
التعبير على هذه البذات عندما وصلوا وصل
الرواد الفضاء الى مركز كندي
للفضاء حيث ساعدوهم على ارتداء هذه البزات
الخاصه التي يذهبون بها الى المحطه
الدوليه طبعا العد العكسي تقريبا ما زال
هناك بدا منذ ساعه وما زال هناك نحو
ساعتين وخمسه وخمسين دقيقه
لانطلاق الصاروخ نحو المحطه الدوليه
جميعنا لا ننتظر هنا كان هناك اجواء
حماسيه يعني اختلطت بمشاعر الفرح خاصه
ومشاعر الاستخاره بالنسبه لاهالي الرائدين
الذين تحدثنا اليهم عندما اتوا هنا
ليودعونهم دعنا نذهب ايضا لنعرف كيف هي
مشاعر الفرح خصوصا لدى السعوديين ن
ذهب ادهان صفيان هاني كيف تتابع الرياض
الرحله السعوديه الى الفضاء الان
نام بك ندين اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه قبل ان نتحدث عن المشاعر وايضا عن
ردود افعال هنا في الشارع السعودي سواء في
العاصمه الرياض او كذلك في باقي مناطق
السعوديه ساتحدث من المكان الذي اقف فيه
وهو المركز الموحد لمهمه اطلاق هذا
الصاروخ الذي صعد للتو الان راعيدي الفضاء
السعوديين ريان وعلي وايضا في هذا المركز
الموحد نشاهد ايضا او يشاهدون
المنسوبي هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه
هنا عمليه الاطلاق الصاروخ وكذلك متابعه
وهي تعتبر من غرف العمليات التي
انشاتها هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه
سواء في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض او كذلك
في باقي مناطق المملكه اضافه الى ان ايضا
الهيئه قامت بتنفيذ وانشاء ثلاثه معارض
معرض في المنطقه الشرقيه وتحديدا مدينه
الخبر وايضا المعرض الاخر في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض والمعرض الثالث والاخير
وهو في المنطقه الغربيه في مدينه جده هذه
المعارض هي تعرض القطع التي سوف يستخدمها
رائدي الفضاء او كذلك رواد الفضاء سواء
السعوديين او الاخرين وكذلك ايضا تعرض
مسار الرحله ومعلومات ايضا عن
عمليات الاطلاق التي نفذت من قبل وكذلك
ايضا تعرض معلومات وفيره وجيده عن محطه
الفضاء الدوليه ايضا تعرض 14 بحثا علميا
وهي البحوث العلميه التي سوف يتم تنفيذها
في المحطه الدوليه من قبل ريانه وعلي منها
الاستمطار ومنها ايضا في مجالات طبيه
ومجالات ايضا في الطيران ومجلات فضائيه
سوف يتم ايضا هذه التجارب سوف يتم تنسيق
بها بشكل
ويتم تنفيذها بشكل مباشر ما اكثر من 12
الف طالبين سعوديين هذه البحوث السعوديه
اليوم السعوديه تسعى من خلال استراتيجيتها
2030 بان تنفذ هذه التجارب على محطه
الفضاء الدوليه وايضا ليس فقط يستفيد منها
السعوديون ولكن ايضا يستفيد تستفيد منها
دول العالم طبعا في هذه او في هذا المركز
تحديدا ايضا يرى مسار انطلاق الصاروخ
صاروخ فالكون وايضا على
وايضا الكبسوله دراغون وهي ايضا متابعه
دقيقه من خلال الشبكات المتصله بين الرياض
وكذلك فلوريدا اذا ما تحدثنا ايضا عن الشق
الاخر والجانب الاخر نتحدث ايضا عن الشارع
السعودي وردود الفعل الفعل بين الشابات
والشباب فمنذ موعد او منذ تحديدا لقاء
رائدين الفضاء بولي الع السعودي قبل قرابه
الشهر وكانت هناك ردود افعال سواء على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي او كذلك من خلال
ايضا احاديثهم في المجالس اليوم هي تعتبر
فرحه مختلفه بالنسبه لهم فالكل كان صغارا
وكبارا وشاهدناه ايضا من خلال المعارض
المقامه كان يتمنى والبعض كان يرتدي بدلات
الفضاء وايضا كان هناك طموح وامال وهناك
احلام تحققت بوجود وراء ايدي الفضاء وما
حققته السعوديه خاصه من صعود او ايضا وجود
هذين الرادين الفضائيين وتوجههم الى محطه
الدوليه للفضاء
الاول باول لهذه المهمه التاريخيه عود
اليك حسين كنت تتحدث عن فرحه الاهالي
وحماسه الناس في هذا اليوم تفضل
نعم نادين تحدثت الى والد علي القرني كان
يعني يشعر بالفخر بابنه حتى انه بكى
امامنا فخرا باذنه هناك مشاعر كان حتى
الوصول اليهم بسبب ضيق الوقت لانه كانوا
عليهم التوجه الى منصه اخرى
حتى من قبل الامريكيين الموظفين في اكسيوم
تحدثت الى عدد منهم اشادوا بعلي
ريان
لاخلاقهما
بعملهما
تصميمهما على
الصعود الى الفضاء قالوا لي كان كان
متعاونين كثيرا مع الفريق الامريكي عندما
كانوا في التدريب في تكساس حيث اجر
الترتيبات الاوليه من التجارب محاكاه
للتجارب من فحوص طبيه اجريت لهم وايضا
كيفيه التصرف في الفضاء كان هناك
تصميم مشابه للمحطه الدوليه موجوده في
تكساس جلسوا
فتره طويله
كمحاكاه لما سيواجهونه في الفضاء خلال
حالات الطوارئ كيف سيتصرفون اخبروني
بانهما كان متعاونين كان متحمسين لديهم
شغف علمي كبير ولذلك حتى الموظفين هناك
كانوا متحمسين للتعامل والتعاون مع هذين
الرائدين السعوديين
البسمه لا تفارق وجههما سيجريان نعم يعني
البسمه لا تفارق وجههما الان حتى الان نحن
نعرض هذه الصور على العربيه نتابع علي
وريانا والفرحه ظاهره والحماس ظاهره على
تعبير وجههما ويلقيان التحيه على كل من
يقف امامهما يوقعان الان طبعا هذه اللحظه
تاريخيه تستحق التاكيد وتستحق
وتستحق ايضا الفخر بان يشعراء بالفخر
لانهما يمثلان وطنهما وللمره الاولى
يمثلان الشباب الشباب العربي الشباب
السعودي والمسلم وخصوصا ايضا بالنسبه
للريانه التي تعد مفخره لبنات وطنها وحتى
ايضا بنات العرب لكي تكون اول عربيه مسلمه
شابه ايضا تخرج الى الفضاء اليوم يتم
الحديث بين السعوديه الى الفضاء في ظل هذه
المرحله وما ستتبعها ايضا من مراحل متعدده
فيما يتعلق بالاستكشافات التي ستخدم
البشريه على الصعيد انجازات طبيه لانه
ايضا هناك الحديث عن الطب في الفضاء سيكون
الاستفاده من التجارب التي ستتم خلال 12
يوما في هذه المهمه وما سيتبعها ايضا من
مهمات اخرى وارسال رواد فضاء اخرين نتابع
معكم ما زلنا ننقل لكم الصور التي تردنا
طبعا الاستعدادات على قدم وساق وصل الرواد
الاربعه الاثنان امريكيان والسعوديان ايضا
الاثنين وصل الان
يوضع عن داخل هذه المركبه يتم ربطهم
باحزمه الامان كما نتابع ايضا البزه
الخاصه في الفضاء وكان ايضا مراسلنا في
فلوريدا حسين تحدث وشرح لنا بان هي بدلات
خاصه صممت لكي تكون مهيئه في الفضاء
بالتحديد ننقل لكم اذا هذه الصور هي على
ما يبدو هناك استعداد كامل بدانا نشاهد
علي وريانا وهما يدخلان الى المركبه لكي
يلحقاه بزملائهما الرائدان الرائدي الفضاء
الامريكيين الذين سيشاركهما في هذه الرحله
طبعا هذه الرحله توصف بانها الى طموحه هي
جزء من برنامج السعوديه لرياده الفضاء
كانت اطلقته الهيئه العامه للفضاء وطبعا
مراسلنا ايضا هاني الصفيان من قلب الحدث
حيث يتابع الجميع من هذه العامه للفضاء
لتاهيل طبعا كوادر سعوديه متمرسه للحديث
عن خوض رحلات فضائيه اما طويله المدى او
قصيره المدى اليوم نحن نتحدث عن هذه
المهمه التاريخيه ستكون لحوالي 12 يوما
وستقوم بعمل اربعه عشره تجربه علميه ستكون
هذه التجارب العلميه متعدده سيتم
الاستفاده ايضا من الفرص الواعده التي
ستقدمها هذه المهمه ويقدمها ايضا قطاع
الفضاء وصناعاته العالميه ايضا سيكون هناك
اسهام في الابحاث هذه التي ستاتي من هذه
المهمه طبعا ستصب في صالح خدمه البشريه في
عدد كبير من المجالات كنا تحدثنا مجالات
الصحه الطب في الفضاء كما اشرنا ايضا
نتحدث عن استدابه وايضا كما اشرنا الى
مساله تكنولوجيا الفضاء اليوم الكل يريد
ان يعرف اكثر فاكثر ماذا في الفضاء هل
يمكن العيش فعلا في الفضاء هل يمكن ان
يكون هناك كوكب اخر غير كوكب الارض يمكن
ان نذهب اليه هل ستكون هناك رحلات الى
الفضاء سياحه الى الفضاء بدل حديث في
الاونه الاخيره عن مساله السياحه الى
الفضاء كل هذه الامور بخدمه رواد الفضاء
وهذه الرحلات الاستكشافيه سيكون هناك
اجوبه عده
ستجيب عن كل الاستفسارات والتساؤلات لدى
العالم وحتى ستفسر كثير من العلم الذي
يطرح في الاونه الاخيره طبعا كنا تحدثنا
بان الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء كانت نشرت في
صور عبر وسائل التواصل الاج معي تحديدا
تويتر صور لمنصه الاطلاق كانت ايضا اظهرت
السداد صاروخ فالك 9 طبعا هذا الصاروخ
مركبه دراغون التي كما نتابعها الان هذه
المركبه التي ستحمل رواد الفضاء الاربعه
ضمن هذه المهمه التي ستنطلق اليوم بعد
منتصف الليل بتوقيت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه المهمه مهمه اي اكس تو ستذهب
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه طبعا كان هناك
حماسه شديده لكل من رائد الفضاء علي
القرني الذي كان ايضا شاركنا بصور له وهو
يستعد ويحمل ايضا حقيبته وهذه المحتويات
التي سيضعها في الحقيبه للسفر الى الفضاء
ريان ايضا كانت نشرت وشاركتنا عبر تويتر
بهذه الصور
للاستعدادات وايضا للتدريب حتى المراجعات
الاخيره
للانطلاق نحو محطه الفضاء الدوليه هناك
ايضا انظر كلها تتجه نحو هذه المهمه التي
توصف بانها الرحله السعوديه الى الفضاء
الاعين الان ايضا نحو اول رائده فضاء
سعوديه وعربيه ومسلمه حيث سينطلق رائده
الفضاء السعوديان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
اي اس اس في رحله طبعا هذه رحله هي رحله
علميه تمثل حدثا تاريخيا بالنسبه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا
تدشن مرحله جديده للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه في مجال الفضاء نحن ننقل لكم هذه
الصور طبعا كما نشاهد الرواد الاربعه
جاهزون ايضا تم ربطهم باحزمه الامان نتابع
معكم هذه الصور والمشاهد على كل حال
نذهب مره اخرى الى مراسلي العربيه لاعطانا
المزيد من التفاصيل هاني اريد ان اعرف كيف
هي الاجواء من عندك من عند الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء اذا تخيلنا وانت تقوم
بجوله الان من داخل هذا المركز كيف هي
الاستعدادات كيف ايضا يتابعون اولا باول
هذه الصور والمعطيات التي تريدهم من
فلوريدا الى الرياض حيث الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء هاني
دعيني نادين اولا اعطي تعريفا بسيطا
برايدي الفضاء طبعا اولا سوف اتحدث عن
راديو الفضاء عن القرني طبعا يعتبر القرني
هو بيحمل بكالوريوس علوم الطيران من كليه
الملك فيصل الجويه في الرياض طبعا هو يحمل
ايضا رتبه نقيب طيار هو طيار على متنه
طائرات الاف خمسه عشر اس اي ولديه خبره
تتجاوز 12 عاما وهو من يقود طائرات ولكن
ليس اي نوع من الطائرات وانما هي طائره
مقاتله من الطراز الجديد التي تمتلكها
السعوديه طبعا حلق في ساعات طيرانه اكثر
من
2387 ساعه طيران اما عن ريانه برناوي وهي
تعتبر اخصائيه ابحاث ومختبرات وتحمل
بكالوريوس او لديها بكالوريوس في علم
الانجاب والهندسه الوراثيه وكذلك في علم
تدوير الانسجه وهي من جامعه اوتاكو في
نيوزلندا لديها ايضا ماجستير في العلوم
الطبيه الحيويه من جامعه الفيصل ولديها
خبره تسعه اعوام في مجال هندسه الخلايا
الجذعيه السرطانيه وتحمل ايضا
من ابحاثها لابحاث الطبيه في الخلايا او
الخلايا الجذعيه التي سوف تقوم
بنقلها وقيام بتجربتها هناك في على محطه
الفضاء الدوليه اما عن باقي المشاعر وكذلك
الحال هنا في المركز الموحد وهو مركز تم
انشاؤه من قبل الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء او
تحديدا هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه
من اجل هذه مهمه اطلاق او صعود راعيدي
الفضاء الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه طبعا ما
زلنا في خلال الساعتين والاربعين دقيقه
هنا على هذه الشاشه ولعلنا اليوم نقوم
بجوله داخل هذا المركز الموحد الذي
نتواجد فيه لدينا ساعتين او ساعتين وتسعه
وثلاثين دقيقه وسبعه او تتجاوز الثواني
وتقل الثواني في لحظه انطلاق رائده فضاء
هذا بث مباشر هنا يتم مراقبته من قبل
كوادر السعوديه درب التدريبا جيدا ويحملون
شهادات في الهندسه وكذلك فنيين واخصائيين
في مجالات الفضاء والاتصالات والتقنيه
اليوم برنامج رواد الفضاء التي تقوم بها
السعوديه وضمن استراتيجيتها لا يقف الامر
عند هذا الحد بل هو فقط ايضا لتطبيق هذه
الابحاث العلميه التي يحملها ريانه وعلي
الى الفضاء ونجاحها سوف يكون بمشاركه مع
12 الف طالب سوف يكون مشترك او تكون بحوث
علميه مشتركه وكذلك بشكل مباشر
مباشر بين محطه الفضاء الدوليه وبين
الرياض اذا اليوم السعوديه لديها
استراتيجيه عاليه في علوم الفضاء ولم يقل
في الامر على هذه البحوث ولكن لديها خطه
ايضا مستقبليه في رفع هذه البحوث العلميه
لتتجاوز العشرات كما اليوم اوضحها لنا عدد
من المستشارين التابعين لهيئه هيئه
الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه عموما ما زلنا
نواكب وايضا نقوم باخذ جوله داخل هذا
المركز الموحد والذي ذكرته قبل قليل انه
تم انشاءه من اجل هذه المهمه ويقوم ايضا
بمتابعه الامر ليس فقط هو النظر وايضا
الاتصال او ايضا
او الدقه في المعلومات ولكن ايضا لديهم
هنا ارقام وسلسله من المهام ينفذونها
هؤلاء الكوادر سواء في علم الاتصالات او
في علوم الفضاء او كذلك في الاتصالات مع
المراكز الموحده في بقيه مناطق السعوديه
او ايضا في فلوريدا
طيب هاني ارجو ان تبقى معنا نحن بالتاكيد
سنكون معكم في سياق هذه التغطيه على شاشه
العربيه
للمهمه السعوديه نحو الفضاء هاني صفيان
ارجو ان تبقى معنا في سياق هذه الساعات
وايضا مراسل العربيه من فلوريدا المتواجد
حيث قاعده الاطلاق حسين الطود شكرا لكما
حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن التاسعه هذا المساء
انتهت ولكن الاخبار بالتاكيد مستمره ولم
تنتهي خصوصا اخبار هذا الحدث التاريخي
الرحله السعوديه الى الفضاء اخبار من
زاويه مختلفه مع زميلي طاهر بركه و360
يسعد مساك طاهر ومساك شكرا كتير نديم
نتابع ايضا في هذه التغطيه لهذا الحدث
التاريخي كوني معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات